あーヌーを航行
これなー後輩通りなぁ cjr 始まる可能とパティと思います
ハマコーさんこうなんかまともに捉えないでください
とりあえずクール料理を爽快されてねとマザー
パスタですパスタパスタを茹でるこれと
これってお名前がわからないんですけどあとこのそのパスタにかけるソースです
これ時世で言うのかいや自炊だろう自分で作ってるです配置図この3点とガスコンロと
か温めるものと水があれば作れます
というわけでまずはこの
これ何ていうんだろう
なぜかな鍋で嫌な目にまず水を入れます
いざもだいたい沸騰して
通してこう溢れてないぐらいの量に行けください
日之影ロスよあの沸騰すればいいんで
ブーブ次のタイミングでどうでもいいと思うんですけど
一人暮らしスプーンのポスターパブーバーですかそんなまあ
鍋に入れても全部したらないんですねここらへんまでしか光らないってパスターをおり
ます
一人暮らし用の多分なればそんな大きくないんで
はぁ
ああ
アーユルねもっとこうプロっぽくしたいんですけどそんなこと言ってられないんだよね
あーこれやねーなこうやっておったらもう全部したるっていい感じです
お箸について公
柔らかさを確認して食べごろになったらと思ったら火を切りますじゃあちょっと
ちょっとじゃねちょっと待つます
今さん分ほどだったんですけどもうちょっとしなってきました
もうちょいですっげーいい感じですこれぐらいじゃにょ知らないですけどこれだけじゃ
ねもう全然フェルト
思いますというわけで火を止めます
ブーン
んペットっ
阿部全武器だこれ一応水入ってるんで戯れに
それを通して
アレス別れる調理の痛いことこういうことです
ん
c
いつもここまで来たらもう言う事はないと思うんですけれど
お皿に茹でたパスタを入れます
本当にこれ料理できる人から見たらはって感じなんですけど出来ない人は出来ないって
僕は知ってるんだよくってみますね
実はこれ今日一緒ダメなんすよもう夕方だけど
まずでおっなんかねほんと男で一人暮らしの人は
つロスますが店で会食だとお金がかかるですね
分ん
うん
ないでござる付パスタもいい感じにはならないんだよ
ほんとこんな感じでやったらもう全然作れるんだよ
作ってみて下さい
ん
me